can you hear us say Joe
can you hear us
perfect I'm the only one speaking so
right we will get underway thank you
very much uh everyone for showing up
here today uh and I'd like to welcome
you to this extraordinary council
meeting to adopt the annual plan the
2023-24 annual plan uh do we have any
apologies um I have one from councilor
Phillips
um and I see that Council Stringer is
online
no further apologies
could I please get a mover to accept
those apologies councilman for now and a
second uh councilor Paul mcphail all
those in favor please say aye
and against motion is carried any
counselor conference interest
there appear to be none
number three adoption of the annual plan
lunae would you like to speak to this
report
uh thank you you worship and through
your worship I'll take the report as
read but there are a couple of points I
would like to highlight in my report and
that uh they are around the end of
identification of it and consistent
decision and the unbalanced budget
as part of our briefings and a part of
the draft annual plan councilman we had
on the 30th of May we talked about
increasing the waste Levy fees at the
transfer station now with with the
decision to increase those to 30 percent
uh this means that we are in breach of
our revenue and financing policy Council
can choose to go outside of the revenue
financing policy and in this instance it
would be considered prudent as it moves
it onto a user pays system
with the long-term plan coming up where
you've got the opportunity to re-look at
how we do our revenue and financing
policy and who pays for what is part of
their process
so there was one item I wanted to draw
elective member's attention to the other
one is around the unbalanced budget now
currently we're sitting at a 1.014
million and deficited budget now this is
on paper only so effectively what that
means is the cash flow of the
organization remains neutral there's
only a four thousand dollar difference
in what we're projecting and the cash
flow movement of the organization
effectively it means the council has not
rated for sufficient Revenue to cover
the non-cash depreciation costs that
we've got so the paper exercise of
depreciation
the funding of this will come through
either reserves or borrowings depending
on the activity
and you know the council has undertaken
some significant Works in recent Years
Around particularly around three Waters
and that's what's driving the unbalanced
budget at the moment
but other than that I'm happy to take
questions
thank you for that Lorne counselors do
we have any questions for Lanai at this
time
uh councilor Garda
just just one um my first question was
on the
um increase in interest rates I just
noted it's not actually just the
increase in interest rates it's the
increase in interest which is
um probably increased interest rates are
probably about 568 000 on our bill but
it's the increase in debt that's come
through in this past year due to
projects finishing that's actually
pushed the interest rates higher so we
need to sort of say well it's not
actually we've done very well and I
think the staff have done very well
keeping our interest rates low and it's
probably only gone up one percent
whereas most people are on the table and
in the
um in that Community would probably have
about a three to four percent raised
rate rise in their interest
and um so council's done very very well
on their interest rates but that's our
debt that's catching up on us and and um
that's probably what we need to address
that in our long-term plan and turning
down debt and probably doing these
projects but that's that's another day
just to come in
thank you councilor councilor Reed
um just a question for Lanae there is
nothing an error Financial policies
which stop us from adopting an
unbalanced budget is there
under the legislation we're required to
adopt a balanced budget but where we
don't we need to identify why we're not
adopting us so we identify what the
adult what it is why it's happened and
why does prudent to do so so there's a
recommendation on page four along those
lines
thank you Lynette and just while I'm
speaking thank you and your team for all
the hard work I know it's been several
workshops and many many hours crunching
numbers
thank you councilor councilor Richard
mcfarrell
you think you worship um just
reaffirming what councilor Garden said
um take one step further that some of
the debt that obviously has been
realized this year has gone some of
those marvelous assets that we've got
around the community and I think
sometimes when we look at it and we take
the brunt of the fact that there has
been expenditure that we do have actual
Hardline and um
bricks and mortar and actually sitting
here
um some of them have been great projects
and and hopefully there'll be some
Legacy projects there too secondly just
in regard to the unbalanced budget
um using the term Legacy what
just confirm the legacy of the
unbalanced budget proceeding into next
year just in this form if you just
explain where we head with that
uh three year you worship
next year it's a chance to reset whether
being a long-term plan we look at
everything from scratch and do
zero-based budgeting and we can look at
our renewals program and
I guess rate appropriately for that or
put fees and charges appropriately for
that so that's part of the long-term
plan discussion that we'll have coming
up but for legacy it just means that we
need to refocus on how we're going to
pay for our renewals and what renewals
we're going to do so maybe as councilor
Gardens said that the elected members
choose to have a reduced renewal program
so that we can pay down dip faster so
there's a few options available that
we'll be talking to councilors over the
next next four five six eight months
I think that explained it very well
thank you councilor councilor McDonald
yeah I've just got a few few comments
here on I'll have to refer to my notes
so I don't waffle on so so please bear
with me I'd like to thank the gore staff
and councils for their hard work on the
annual plan we have certainly reduced
our costs we started off with a a budget
that was looking at over 20 rates rise
of over 20 plus I'd like to publicly
thank lornay Strait The Chief Financial
Officer for efforts in reducing the rate
increase and also the other senior
management team members and also the
rest of the council staff who have
contributed to the reduction and costs
since we first looked at a much higher
rate increase we have an unbalanced
budget but we have a a depreciation pool
of over seven million dollars which will
cover that adequately cover the
shortfall we use the balance of the
depreciation to to buy and replace
Capital assets and our depreciation is a
very high part of our costs at over 20
around 25 percent
I'll be asking the the Chief Financial
Officer to present the to the audit and
risk Committee of council the the
detailed capital budget so the
councilors can come familiar with it
over the for the 23 24 year the
long-term plan will in the long-term
plan we'll be discussing debt repayment
and we'll be using depreciation money to
focus on on to focus on this the level
of debt the council has is a major
concern to many rate payers and all
councilors and all councilors we we need
a detailed plan going forward to repay
this debt and this will be addressed in
the long-term plan there are only three
options realistically to deal with our
debt via depreciation sell assets or
rate for for around two million dollars
a year increase in rates that's the 10
rise and Zone and that is just not an
option
with with the debt the borrower needs to
be the master not the debt to be the
master you need to have a master plan
and stick to it consistently
yes so yeah
thank you listening
thank you for that speech counselor I
think you touched on some some important
points uh throughout that
any further questions comments
from the floor
no it doesn't seem to be I I'd just like
to further counselors comments around
the table and just come in the hard work
that lornay and the team have put in um
to develop this plan uh it was obviously
put in a condensed time frame with the
Union report coming so late and the year
so they've done a tremendous effort and
given the current economic state of the
country it is incredibly hard to keep
this rate rise down with that that being
said I did want to touch on some points
that um Stuart made there sorry Council
and MacDonald
um
there are options
um that he alluded to around bringing
down debt but I think the key one that
has been expressed not only in this
Council but also councils around the
country uh is that the rating system is
overdue for a refresh and we do need to
look at bigger better funding options
across the country that's where I have
this beautiful document that has
recently been released which is the
future for local government and I think
it's prudent that we as a council and
also we as a nation uh start to get into
robust debates about how we are going to
fund local government because rates are
highly disparaged against taxes and
we're trying to do a lot more with a lot
less money so
that is another option that we also need
to be looking at and as Lorne very
rightly put out stated sorry uh the
long-term plan is a great opportunity
for a reset and to re-look at the model
completely
so while I am
saddens that the rate rise is double
digits I do look across the country and
we are in the middle pack so we're not
irregular by any means and I know this
Council will try incredibly hard over
the long-term plan period to keep those
rates down and to benefit our community
to the best of our ability
Council got on
just to comment on your increasing
income through that report I was very
pleased to see that they are suggesting
that the council keep the 15 GST on the
rates and house instead of paying a tax
on a tax to central government
but whether that comes to future or or
hope it does I mean
you're correct the counselor uh the
other part that I saw in there and it
was a comment uh race at the the
previous meeting by councilor hovel
around Reserve Land and how much that we
have per capita in this report it does
talk about being paid for Crown Land so
that could be a huge benefit to a
district like ours
actually receiving some income for some
of the land that we're holding
so I have a mover for the
recommendations here they are quite long
so if everyone's happy or doesn't have
any changes I'm just happy to move them
in a bunch counselor mcdonell and the
seconder
councilor Richard mcfail
any further discussion or changes to
these recommendations
I will put oh cancer Dixon
I think you worship I'd just like to say
that
um I think it's really difficult when
central government keeps pushing costs
onto local bodies and that is also
driven up air rates and I know that
probably the community and the rate pays
and I'm one of those will be very
disappointed with the double digits but
I can see how hard work has got into
bringing this rate rise down and
appreciate that but I do think we do
have to think about what central
government is doing to local bodies
thank you
thank you councilor uh and and totally
agree
um and that there has been
um
there has been an indication from the
current government to work with local
government if they lead the change
hopefully that stays the same with
whatever government takes control as of
October 14th
any further comments
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye aye and against
the motion is carried thank you
counselors
item number four rates resolution
speak to us at all
uh thank you Russia the document is one
of those formal documents that are
required by legislation to be
um
be adopted by Council I don't think
there's much point in going through it
line by line so I'll take it as read
thank you for that we'll know do we have
any further comments from counselors
could I please get a mover for all of
those
together
uh councilor McDonough is the Mover and
a secondary councilor Dixon
just before I put that motion I just
want to make it uh clear for the public
listening
um and also the media that the rate rise
that we just adopted is an average of
10.97 percent
so it wasn't the 11.58 that we're at for
the drafts and it's come down slightly
to 10.97
no further comments I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye aye
and against
the motion is carried thank you
councilors
uh proposed fees and charges
I think of your worship um this is a
follow-on from our meeting on the 30th
of May one of the things I would like to
draw attention to is a slight
typographical error on page 29 of the
agenda and it relates to the swimming
for swimming fees for charges for over
60 to 79 year olds this is should be
five dollars if not no charge though no
charge relates to 80 80 years and over
so just a small typo there that we will
correct one thing I would like to bring
to elected members attention is that
we're proposing to introduce this from
the 1st of August not the first of July
this is for operational reasons so we've
got time to do the background work and
updating our signage and updating a
website and and booking system and on
and so that just gives that the staff
time to to implement them and give us a
wee bit of extra time for the public to
adjust to the upcoming changes
thank you Lorna just on that point will
there be immediate signage of the there
will be changes so while the signage is
being done just even if it's eight Falls
just saying changes are coming
but people can prepare for the change
uh through the cheer I think we'll be
able to articulate quite clearly what
through various channels that um yeah
that there is impending changes to our
fees and charges
awesome thanks for that Sonia uh any
questions for lornay from counselors
doesn't seem to be any open cancel the
read
thank you Mr B um Lanae I see it under
libraries
um
no charge for adult fiction or no charge
on magazines is this a new policy
from the manager yes
um I know the library did put it up to
ask would that there be no charge and
elected members can choose to
revert back to the old charges that were
there yeah yeah I do remember the
library manager speaking to that
um a couple of years ago and she was it
is a way of encouraging people to come
back to the library and use books and
actually use our beautiful new facility
so
I'm pleased to see that in Neil around
thank you councilor councilor
um and sorry just in relation to the
library they they will come into force
on the first of July
oh the the so the current no charge
regime that we've got on books we
resolved was for the period ending 30
June so I assume the no charge will
start on the first of July not first of
August or any other days
[Music]
three worship that is up to elected
members my proposal or the report
suggests that all fees and charges will
change on the 1st of August
um but and I do appreciate it a previous
council meeting that when their library
was opened that there was a waiver till
the 30th 30th of June elector members
that's given that the charges are not
changing wholesale from what they were
previously I think members can choose to
whether they'd like the first of July or
first of August
Thank you Lorne thank you councilor I
guess that's a good catch of we would
want it to continue as as rather than
confusing Library staff for a month
so if we can make that change do we need
to add that in the recommendation
somewhere
I might just add to the end of that
recommendation except Library charges
so just adding to the bottom of the
recommendation commencement date of one
August 2023 except Library charges which
will come into effect first of July
so it makes sense dear Susan
cool
any further comments from councilors
no could I please have a mover of that
recommendation councilor Guardian
seconded by councilor Reed
any further discussion
no I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried
it brings us to the end
just like that
uh thank you very much for
um attending here today councilors and
those in attendance